[Music]
welcome back everybody to blender as a
video editor part three
blender 3.0 specifically also part three
we're going to talk all about
transitioning your videos
and some of the effects you can do
that's that's the main focus of this
particular video so hopefully you've
seen the first at least the first
episode to know about this whole setup
and interface and how we got to this
with the video and that's all in episode
one so go check that out if you're not
even sure how to get to this phase
because i've already got all that set up
here and what i've got here is about an
hour and 30 minutes long uh just magic
uh the gathering arena match it doesn't
that doesn't really matter it's just
that
uh it's a video that i can
example some transitions with so of
course we have a video file and a sound
file we're just going to look for a good
point to maybe make a transition and
here looks like a pretty good one so
usually you want to transition to the
beginning of matches for these type of
videos
i would say so let's go ahead and make a
cut right here now since we're going to
transition here maybe we'll do a fade
maybe we'll do a wipe we'll decide that
in a minute but we need to get the right
kind of cut and we can either do a soft
cut or a hard cut now it doesn't
actually matter a whole lot what you do
you just have to be aware of the
limitations we covered a ton of that
and basically the first two episodes as
well
for this case we're going to be doing
soft cuts so i just pressed k
and if you go over here to the bottom
left you see you get a softer hard
i'm going to keep it soft now the only
thing the only difference is
if you do a hard cut you can't pull this
back over
that's really the only difference was
with a soft cut like we have here i've
got a little leeway of uh space
which might be useful in these
transitions
so i'm going to find a point here where
it looks like it goes into a lull
lol which is about right
about right here
it's a very short period and i'm just
going to hit another soft cut
so this little period in between
is not what we want but actually it
looks like i cut it a little too soon
just a tiny bit too soon
so i'm zooming way in here with the
mouse wheel
and scrolling over so it looks like i
actually want the cut to be about right
here so i'm going to hold ctrl after
grabbing those two ends you know ctrl
click the ends hit g hit ctrl again and
it snaps
to different parts so snap in there
looks
good
we actually want this one to be a little
bit longer there that's what we wanted
so we want that to be right to the end
of where we were deck building there
see right there boom and then it kind of
fades out naturally with how the video
is
so
yeah about that frame is pretty good oh
we actually got it too soon now so
actually right there is really good and
this whole section right here is useless
we don't want it it's just this right no
good
i don't need that in a video so i'm just
going to hit the delete key
so
ctrl z just undo it if you make a
mistake i just selected the box delete
and there we go now we've got our
section we want to go from here to here
and we want to do it a nice smooth
transition style so what we're going to
do
is
well we could do an l cut or a j cut now
i'm not like a video editing whiz and i
don't know all the theory i didn't go to
school for it i'm a computer scientist
so
whether you do an l cut or a j cut is up
to you i'm just going to show you how to
do them
uh not necessarily the best thing so
oh i better explain this too
so you can
if you have your cursor somewhere on the
left everything on the right is what's
upcoming and if you hover your cursor in
this area the sequencer area and press
backspace
it removes the gap
so that's really handy when you're going
along and editing to just remove gaps
so we want maybe
the pre-audio of the next one
going like this i guess this would be a
j-cut so since we did soft cuts i can
just pull this over
i don't know how much to do
i think they usually say like two
seconds or something uh so we're going
to look up here on the timeline it
looks like it's splitting right there
about 1835 there's 1834 1833 so we'll
just pull it back to somewhere around
here
all right very good and what we want to
do is take
uh i don't know if this is a problem i'm
probably saying this terminology wrong
so don't quote me or correct me
or do correct me in the comments if you
want it's fine we're going to get rid of
this particular audio and just pull it
back like that
and now we have this empty space of
audio well it's not empty it's this new
audio that we're going to transition to
so this probably actually wouldn't look
bad is just a sharp
boop ready
but
we can do one better so let's take this
clip here
and pull it back in
maybe about there we don't want to do it
the full sound length
i don't think
and then
to crossfade these you got to click them
both so you need shift for this you
click first one hold shift
hold shift and then click the other one
and now you got both selected when you
have them both selected
uh you can there's a couple ways to do
this you can go to add
transition
and you can do a cross a gamma cross or
a wipe
they're all
something different you can also just i
think
you right click yeah you can right click
up here and get it
or right click in here
and you'll also get options to like add
transition so there are multiple ways i
think you can like even commit is a
command shift a control shift a
i don't know no it's a just shift day
like with shift a you can get a menu too
so there's three different ways to get
this menu which might just make it more
confusing so once you have these two
clips selected i guess you can just use
box shift instead of select and i am
over explaining on purpose so
just to make sure it sticks so you can
either go to add transition right click
add transition shift a
add transition there's just tons of ways
to get to add transition it's just the
way blender is the way they designed it
they want to give you workflow options
or something i don't know what their
design decision is for that kind of
weird if you ask me all i would say just
leave it in the menu
and give me a hot key you know that's my
preference but they just want to like
give you tons of ways so now that we
have both these selected let's pick one
of those ways of clicking add transition
and we're going to do a wipe now it
crosses just do like a cross fade which
is kind of cool it's fine you know just
you know fade one end or fade one out
fade the other one in the wipe is where
you get something sweet so once you add
it you get this new area here that is
your process of of the thing you can
like click
your thing into it and see what it's
looking like see it's got this uh you
can see it's cross fading up like so
more oh that's kind of cool or down i
guess actually
and
if you click this little wipe you get
the uh specifications over over here
properties i guess you would call it
there's transition type we got single
right now you can change it to double
and you can see what that'll look like
so you can play around with these and uh
go to your heart's content with what you
want to look like you can do a nice iris
effect that's pretty cool i really like
this actually i think that's probably
ideal for this type of thing it's like
perfect
just right into the ready i like it
so we're going to stick with iris
there's also clock you can imagine what
that does there's direction in and out
which you can imagine what that does
and that might actually be cooler
i don't know i kind of like the out
because it shows the ready
in this particular case but that's just
my preference alright and then blur
width is for these little edges
uh you can change it as desired make it
look a little more dreamy or whatever i
kind of like it right about
there actually i think that's kind of
cool that's a huge blur with it's really
huge
and
uh you'll see some more stuff
and to be honest i never ever mess with
these in fades uh you can if you want
you can see what kind of cool effects
you can get with transform crop video
color and stuff
but it's just not something i typically
do because uh
the simple fade like this is like plenty
out for what what i'm doing here i don't
know what this would do what would this
do
apparently it's cropping the whole wipe
area i'm just i'm just out of curiosity
okay
so i guess if you want to do some sort
of special
you know that doesn't really work here
in my opinion but there there's always
cases where you want to do this stuff so
it's nice to have the options available
and that right there is the main way you
do a transition
so we're going to do a little demo
render of this so i'm going to click
here
make it a start point
and i'm going to go over here a little
past it
and make it an endpoint
and now you can see that this area is a
lighter gray
and if we go to render
we will get a result that we can
observe of course you want to work
through your whole video doing all these
and then render the whole thing but if
you just want to sample what one section
looks like and maybe hitting play on
this is like too laggy or too slow which
is now i just hit play and it still
hasn't played
probably because i'm recording to the
same drive i'm pulling this data off of
so it's like
it takes a lot of caching for a drive to
do all that
so that's probably my reason but anyway
in any case we're going to go up here to
render and render animation now of
course before you do this if you haven't
seen the first couple episodes i talk
all about how to render properly mainly
in the first video so i've already got
all that stuff set up
and that's why we just go to render
render animation and let it do its thing
and i'll come back with the results
alright so i got it rendered and it
turns out i had this looping in the
background so you guys probably heard it
over and over
uh
sorry about that
anyway uh
i also realized when i was rendering
that this isn't really a good end point
because it just ends like right here
so you know maybe there's a case to
to say it's better to cut over here or
something
you know like right here
and do that
and that's easy we just make a soft cut
delete this and when we delete it its
transition goes away there because it
doesn't know what to do with it anymore
now we go something like this
pull it back
uh create a little overlap here like we
did before and just redo it
right that's all we gotta do another
transition in there
wipe we chose iris
out with around a point five i don't
know let's see what it looks like now
we're just going further in the video
closer to the match start in this
particular game and that looks that's
probably better right so let's render
that one
uh pause
we're gonna go with slightly different
numbers
just go a little further out there
and render render animation this
actually happens quite quick since the
small part but uh come back with results
we'll watch both videos here in a moment
there's the verses yeah uh okay i guess
i don't need to pause it's already done
already done rendering that's the end of
the render
and to find those of course you go to
where your output was we chose our
rendered folder
so we're just going to go there
in our file explorer on our computer
we'll see it right here with these these
names and let's just give these a quick
watch to see how they
rendered in the final trend
got it on my screen here we go
this is the second one or no this is the
first transition
as you can see it renders in that blur
decent little transition there right
let's check the other one
we effectively did about the same thing
just whoa whoa whoa
okay the way i have the audio on this
one i don't like actually so i would
change that the way i tried to do the a
jacob or what i'm calling a j cut i
don't know if it's a proper one
i guess it's not too bad but i would
probably tweak that a little bit more
personally or maybe just leave it
uh if you're not like a full-time editor
sometimes you just got to get the stuff
done quickly and it's a little janky and
it's whatever at least you put some
edited into it
but uh yeah yeah i get it so that's it
that's the video that's how you do
transitions i mean if you have any
questions you can also crossfade sounds
in a very similar way i guess i'll throw
that in at the end you just select them
both go to transition or crossfade towns
is right here instead of the transition
normally you see transition right there
i think
i don't know wait
not seeing it here we go
oh they gotta overlap
so they would have to we could do that
we could say all right let's just
do this
transition sound crossfade now i don't
know what the difference is between that
sound crossfade i'm bringing that one up
with shift a it's the same when you find
this ad if you right click you get this
crossfade sounds option
and i don't know what the difference is
there but it looks like it just auto
keyframes and let me get this zoomed in
you can see here the fade in
and the fade out so it looks like it
just kind of automatically does that and
we can take a quick listen here
without rendering
it's kind of lagging there
people will let it replay once to
and it still seems a little awkward to
me but it's not bad so you can see you
can play around with that kind of stuff
in your video
you're right in blender and you got a
lot of control over a lot of custom
options for how you want to do that
transition all right thanks for watching
see you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you